and there's big joe getting his warm-up
tosses in see him out there for a while
see there was just three games before he
had to go on the show 14 innings a
little wild that's one of the things
that really showed he wasn't feeling
feeling well there was a health problem
11 walks in 14 innings so we're ready to
play and play we will
that one pulled into right and it's in
there for a base hit half around first
on his way to second base and he's going
to make it cubs have a man at third two
down no score top of the first and it's
up to javier baez to give the cubs the
lead
that ball had a lot of english on it
escrow shovels it to first and that
lead-off double left on for the cubs
veteran pitcher kyle hendricks a little
short armor with not a lot of velocity
but moves the ball around has a lot of
movement on his two seam fastball it's
been getting hit a little bit this year
though hendricks to work out of the
stretch for the first time scoreless
game bottom of the first josh bell at
the plate
bell hits a high pop fly
and it's maven and right and he's got it
and that's it for the pirates they
strand one after an inning
here's the two two and a swing and a
miss as sousa chased another pitch out
of the strike zone low and away second
strikeout for musgrove it's two down
cameron maben the batter
and moscow makes quick work he strikes
him out
three k's for musgrove through two moran
two for four last night as the
designated hitter also drew a walk
driven out to right center colin moran
with a home run
it left the ballpark and moran with his
seventh home run puts the pirates in the
lead it cleared those slow seats in
right center one hop splash so colin
moran puts one in the allegheny
so eight in a row sent down by musgrove
and musgrove has sent down nine in a row
great return for joe
here's rizzo anthony grounded out to
short his first time joe musgrove is
ready the lead at first by contreras
rizzo pulls one to right that's gonna
get to the wall
contreras on his way to third
it's a double for rizzo and the cubs are
in business
so musgrove was sterling through the
first three he had retired nine cubs in
a row but with the cubs threatening here
he's starting to tire in that first
start back and nick tropiano will pick
up here in the fourth cubs at second and
third nobody out fourth inning pirates
lead one nothing but javier baez would
like to rearrange that scoreboard right
now infield in
high and deep to the left and it will
go
three to one
get out the tape measure for javier baez
a long three run homer and the cubs lead
three to one well tropiano comes in and
he throws first pitch heater and javi
didn't miss it he hits this ball a ton
to left center field and there might
have been catcher's interference there
horner on the swing hit the glove of the
catcher stalling stallings got too close
to the batter and now the cubs have the
bases loaded
and he pops him up on the first pitch
hayes
has the out
so a couple of singles
with two outs and jacob stallings
yep
to third an easy play boat he just steps
on the bag and that'll
[Music]
how can that not put a smile on your
face what a delightful entrance music
for with you
mr holland tonight well there's none
better than mr rogers baez in the box he
hit a three-run shot his last time up
and the strikeout of baez colin starts
off with the mr rogers kicks tonight one
two three
kyle hendricks kyle's still
on the mound he is at 86 pitches let's
see how far he can go
swing and
the miss
he struck him out again third time
tonight reference the master class
earlier
this is the
unwitting pupil here this evening
second and third one down here's anthony
rizzo now the 1-1 to anthony swinging a
ground ball toward the middle base hit
center field this is going to drive in
too
horner scores contreras scores cubs lead
5-1
and anthony alford will lead things off
he's one for two
offered out toward the notch and deep
and alford hit this one off the bullpen
roof
wow
what a blast for anthony alford his
first pirates home run
makes it 5-2
that is a
base hit i believe trapped out and left
and now he caught it they saying he
caught it oh man i don't know
i think that was a short hop
if they decide it wasn't a catch they're
gonna have to figure out where all the
base runners go yeah you see the bullpen
motion signaling let's challenge this
thing yeah yeah yeah
okay no catch
run in
second
top three in the order for the cubs
tonight have combined for seven hits
round ball
oh right through the legs of newman the
cubs are gonna get a couple
eight to two
two away in the bottom of the night
here's jacob stallings
bodhi will throw to first cubs win cubs
win they'll go for a sweep and a winning
road trip tomorrow